hey guys i'm ryan right so today i'm
gonna be doing a spoiler talk of
Jurassic world before I go went to this
I do want to say that I actually went
online I went on rotten tomatoes I went
through a [ __ ] ton of reviews there I
went on Mo's no tyro Magnus Jeremy Jones
Chris Stockman I wanted to hear opinions
of what people thought about this I I
know for sure what I felt but I was
curious to see what other people were
saying and I normally don't do that
before I do a review I was kind of
surprised like where some of the
criticisms were and a lot of the
negativity was aimed towards so I do
feel compelled to like really do a
spoiler talking and immediately do one
instead of doing a non-spoiler review I
figured most of the people have been
asking for a review I have already seen
the film so here I am let's get into
this alright just for starters I [ __ ]
enjoyed the hell out of this film I
thought it was a total blast super
entertaining
I mean it's fair to say that if you go
in with the mentality of wanting to see
something similar to the first Jurassic
Park you're probably not gonna walk out
to happy but then again I rewatched the
first film the night before and I didn't
have a hard time readjusting to the tone
of this sequel I mean it is completely
different in tone but it's still a huge
entertaining sweeping spectacle man and
yeah it's fun thrills but it's also like
suspenseful fun thrills you hear a lot
of movies that are like really fun
really thrilling but rarely do you hear
them used the word suspenseful I mean a
lot of times cliche sure it's cheesy a
good amount at the time - yeah but for
this particular film it actually works
like a big reasons why I actually like
this film is because it was very
self-aware you could tell it was
self-aware in the in the way they were
creating this movie and like often times
things that I thought were stupid that I
heard in the trailer they actually
explained it pretty well in the movie
like when I heard that they're making a
hybrid dinosaur my first thought was
what a stupid idea why would they do
that early on in the film they lay out a
really good explanation as to why they
did it
I mean first off in real life we already
do that to animals there's already gene
splicing going on and this is a
different type of world in this world
dinosaurs have been resurrected
years now so people have kind of become
immune to the fact of this they're not
loud by it anymore it's a different type
of world it puts you in a world where
Jurassic Park is not some secret thing
they're working on it's like a science
fiction tale with a twist on modern day
like the first one dealt with what if
they brought dinosaurs back to life what
would happen this one is about what if
the parks successfully opened I mean it
covers a lot of things that I thought
really worked like how people have
become immune to dinosaur thrills that
does sound like our day and age and it's
interesting because we can watch the
first film it's built off this vision
and huge ambition from John Hammond he
mainly wants to share it with the world
yes money is involved but there's a much
deeper cause behind why he wants this
part to open but in this film the park
is now open but it's very much corporate
run and that just makes sense you know
it's a business it's an amusement park
so of course it's gonna be run like a
corporation like in order for any of
this to exist it takes a lot of money so
they need some very wealthy investors so
why wouldn't their main concern be
making profit and even Chris Pratt
acknowledges the issue of a hybrid
dinosaur that I was thinking where he
was like wow aren't dinosaurs enough and
what I really love that this film did
different is that yeah upfront it's
established there's a villainous
dinosaur it's a hybrid dinosaur they
call it the indominus rex which I
thought was an awesome [ __ ] creation
if you look at the first three Jurassic
Park films it's more about surviving the
island and being surrounded by a world
of herbivores and carnivores and while
there is usually those dinosaurs that do
get to shine and the scary things like
it's usually the t-rex and the Raptors
they were never really the main focus of
the film they were an ingredient to the
movie like the opening shot of this film
the hybrid dinosaurs are being hatched
like it establishes right up front this
film is about the indominus rex which
made it like a traditional entertaining
monster flick like it was aware that
they couldn't just duplicate Jurassic
Park and but they knew that people were
gonna be waiting around for the thrills
which made it like a traditional
entertaining monster flick if you look
at the first Jurassic Park first half of
it is like wow look how beautiful all
this is Wonder
ah and the second half is just flipped
around it's all been sucking terrifying
it really is terrifying the film pretty
much seemed aware that they couldn't
duplicate that which I admired that they
were aware that they couldn't duplicate
it people are saying Jurassic world
doesn't have the same sense of wonder
and awe but I'm like you can't really do
that again we've already been exposed to
the Wonder and awe and then we had the
Wonder and awe [ __ ] flipped on our
faces and it was just terrifying so
we're not gonna really be sitting around
wondering ah but there were times where
I was like well I am finding myself
going like that is pretty [ __ ] cool
to see like if you look at the lost
world in Jurassic Park 3 they're
essentially [ __ ] replicas of the
first one there's a lot of been there
done that the film won't for something
completely different rather than about
being surviving and trying to get off
the island it's about trying to protect
the people on the island
it's about this dinosaur that has broken
free roaming around on this island it's
getting closer and closer to people I
like how it had like that a ticking time
clock about it like they have to stop it
before it gets to all the tourists so
it's like a movie about a hunt to take
down a monster
so being self-aware knowing that the
audience is gonna be wanting the terror
to kick in please that was everything
well in the first act they set up the
indominus rex really well they set up
the characters decently enough like
Bryce Dallas Howard characters kind of
like Jon Hamm and not fully but kind of
in the sense that she's not
mean-spirited she's not necessarily
greedy and corrupted she's just trying
to do the right things at least the
right things to get her job done in this
other area I was really worried about
how this other area would turn out but
it's one of the reasons why this film is
cool in its own right with Chris Pratt
training the Raptors the fact that Chris
Pratt can train the Raptors like if
something like that was in the first one
because of the way the first one is made
it wouldn't make sense it wouldn't even
make sense for part 2 & 3
it just wouldn't match it would
translate his total [ __ ] but because
of the different vibe the different
world like it's really important to
realize this is now a different world
before it was like there's a secret
thing in our world that we all live in
and it's a dinosaur island now it's a
different world because everyone knows
about it it's like a more amped of
science fiction film like a more
fictional world that people live in
amongst dinosaurs or at least knowing
the dinosaurs live somewhere in the
world and having prior knowledge of
knowing that Raptors are really
intelligent creatures they made it work
like surprisingly well like I don't know
anything about dinosaurs like really so
I can't sit here and be like how do you
know it's not possible because maybe
there is someone who knows as possible
about the end of the day it was [ __ ]
forever ago so maybe we could be able to
have trained a raptor if like we brought
a raptor back to like I bought it like
another reason why it worked is because
Chris Pratt wasn't like man's best
friend with these Raptors like the
Raptors always seem like confused on how
to respond to him like emotionally
confused on whether or not they should
trust Chris Pratt so it gives you that
vibe that at any moment the Raptors
could possibly turn on him that's why
Chris Pratt always has to establish his
dominance he always [ __ ] the Raptors
and yes no that's not what he does it
wasn't like how the trailer made it out
to be where it looked like Chris Pratt
will be able to call upon his Raptors to
kick some ass his character even says
that he pretty much can't do that
because of the type of animal they are
now there are other characters that have
been receiving a lot of complaints I
noticed but if you like the issues
people are making with these characters
are bigger than they need to be yes the
first dress apart had really
well-thought-out characters great acting
I know I'm sorry this is in Jurassic
Park this is Jurassic world now and it's
a different kind of film and the
characters might not be as strong but
they're good enough for what this film
is like a lot of people are going after
the two kids Zack and gray I think yes
this little weird gray is set up pretty
simple he's a enthusiastic young lad who
really is obsessed with Dinosaurs Zack
is a man who seems pretty intent on
cheating on his girlfriend I personally
wasn't a fan of the performance the
writing of it wasn't the greatest but in
a way it did feel the character was
necessary in order to convey the message
that Bryce Dallas Howard kept trying to
convey which is hey people are immune
they don't really give a [ __ ] about the
dinosaur anymore and you see that this
guy looks like bored a lot
the time on the island he just spends
his time like staring at girls like in a
really creepy way like he was doing like
Edward Cullen maneuvers but does not
have the powers of Everett Cullen so
it's not gonna work and then at one
point they have this thing brought up
that I really wish they did bring a
conclusion to actually where they were
talking about the parents possibly
getting divorced because I forgot the
actors names think once Judi something
Greer and the other guy [ __ ] really
should do the names first like are you
doing right now but I'm not going to but
the people who played their parents
they're really good actors and then they
talk about how they're probably going
through a divorce and the kid has a
great scene with a little one gray
because he's like crying about it and I
I really bought it as his kid who's like
trying to deal with his parents getting
a divorce
but they never wrapped that storyline up
like I feel like a lot of the issues
people had with the characters could
have easily been solved if they just
gave some conclusions to the characters
one thing I really like about the first
rest party if you look at dr. grant he
starts off not liking kids then because
of the terrifying adventure he gets put
in a position where he has to love and
care for these two children who are
strangers to him but he really learns to
take care of them and the film ends with
like a subtle hint that he probably
wants kids now so there's a character
set up but because of the adventure it
caused dr. grant to actually go through
an arc in this film they're saying of
stuff for us to care about the kids for
but once they get thrown into the midst
of the terror they don't even bother to
conclude the storylines it just gets
canned and the other major character
that's complained about which I actually
do get this one the most which sucks
because I really love this actor and I
still don't know if I pronounce his name
right Vincent D'Onofrio he plays like
the man who represents the military he
wants to be able to have the government
be able to use raptors because he sees
that dinosaurs can be trained and they
can be better weapons than what they
currently have but a lot of people just
have issues with that fact right there
but I really didn't you have to look at
this in terms of a world that now
accepts the resurrection of dinosaurs
like two decades have passed it's mainly
kids who go to amusement parks so by
this point in time with mainly kids and
teenagers
being born into a world knowing of
dinosaurs already-existing they're not
gonna be so wowed by it it's like an old
person might be wowed by an iPhone still
today because they lived in a time where
the iPhone didn't exist people who are
born into a time where the iPhone exists
they don't really appreciate its
invention it's why I'm comparing the
creation of dinosaurs to an iPhone so
that's one side to this world and as
cheesy as it sounds the military wants
to use Raptors to fight it's cheesy yeah
it sounds [ __ ] cheesy but it works
for this movie it makes sense at the
time because it takes place in this
fictitious world and the fictitious
world that it's evolved into it makes
sense to me that there would be that man
who's like whoa
we could have a monster on our side we
could have a team of these clever
creatures these monsters that we can you
know control they think they can control
them and they would do better like it
made sense to me that they would want to
use it as a weapon but anyway yeah the
first 25 minutes of this film sets up
the character sets up the indominus rex
and then the adventure begins now the
indominus rex is pretty [ __ ] scary I
wish we had gotten some cool animatronic
shots of it honestly I don't think we
ever did but I'm pretty sure it was
computer-generated the whole time at
least it seemed that way to me it looked
terrifying and it had a different
personality like I love how Chris Pratt
scared okay first off Chris Pratt I
thought he was awesome in this movie
like I thought he would just be Chris
Pratt again I thought you would pretty
much be who he wasn't guardians of the
galaxy yes it was like personality
charms with certain characteristics that
we do love of Chris Pratt but he's more
toned down he's more serious he's more
brooding a [ __ ] awesome in this role
I mean especially after watching this
film I totally get why he was being
rumored for the next Indiana Jones like
Chris Pratt's character is smart while
everyone else is like we created them so
we own them we can control them he
understands them as animals like that
moment where he's describing how it's
kind of bad how they're feeding the
indominus rex how that crane is the only
thing that it really has an emotional
attachment to or some type of
relationship because this dinosaur
doesn't live in a community at all so he
gets that it would be vicious that it
would kill anything in its path because
it just doesn't understand things that
if the dinosaur got out of that specific
section where they're keeping it
everything would
like brand-new to this dinosaur it's
like a gene splice animal yet it goes
back to that argument of like nature
versus nurture so they give the
indominus rex a personality of like a
creature where everything is new in its
sight it's almost like a hungry giant
dinosaur that is kind of childlike but
even that right there with the indominus
rex the film is self-aware even naming
the dinosaur the indominus rex like
Chris Pratt's character laughs when he
first hears the name but they give an
explanation as to why they named the
dinosaur that and immediately I was like
oh yeah one thing I think that's
important to understand is that Jurassic
Park has been categorized in many genres
but I feel like people forget that
science fiction is one of its main
components they put it under adventure
they put it under thriller they put it
under horror film a lot too but for some
reason I rarely hear people say science
fiction but this film it really up to
the science fiction factor and they even
messed with the gene splicing stuff a
lot more in the first one they talk
about how to fill in the rest of the DNA
molecules or some other scientific [ __ ]
that they take DNA strands from frogs to
complete the DNA makeup
hopefully I'm saying it's all right
which allowed certain dinosaurs to
change from female into male because
certain frogs can do that and this film
may take it to all like a much bigger
step like the indominus rex is comprised
of many things so it kind of gets like
unique powers like it has this really
scary moment where it has the ability to
camouflage itself it was really well
played out and the that scene they
released a clip of it and I thought it
looked stupid but then when I saw the
film I was like this whole scene
actually is [ __ ] intense like I love
those money shots of when like Chris
Pratt is under the car and he's pouring
the gasoline all over really fast my
first thought when this movie ended is
Chris Pratt must smell real bad because
Bryce Dallas Howard says in the first
act of Chris Pratt that you know he
pretty much smells like [ __ ] and then
throughout the movie he's running around
after he poured a bunch of gasoline on
himself he is sweating like crazy his
clothes are getting worn out he's
falling in dirt and [ __ ] so I imagine
that he just smelled awful I just want
to point that out but that scene you
know that money shot where Chris Pratt's
under the car and the teeth appear and
there's the
in the tea it was [ __ ] terrifying
like especially on IMAX I gotta say if
you saw this film I don't care what your
opinion is if you didn't see it on IMAX
you got to check it out the IMAX 3d
experience is [ __ ] awesome it's more
than just a bigger screen it really does
make the adventure that much more fun
but yes the deaths are more brutal but
with the indominus rex what's really
cool is like I was kind of sitting there
going oh will they defeat this dinosaur
exactly because this dinosaur was really
[ __ ] smart like one thing with the
t-rex was if you don't move it can't
know you're there won't see you but it
seemed like with the indominus rex that
it didn't matter if you were still or
not it would be able to see it would
still be able to pick up on you like the
indominus rex is a terrifying monster
like it's scary when they're hunting the
dinosaur and they say ok there's a
tracker in it so that's how we'll find
it and the [ __ ] trailer gave it away
but I was so pulled into the movie that
it's a scary moment where they just see
this like pound of flesh from the
dinosaur that it was willing to just
carve out its own flesh to get the
tracker out and tracker in it like when
the kids are in that rolling spear glass
thing and they are being attacked by the
indominus rex that was intense I mean
yeah I know they probably would have
died like just from how the dinosaur was
just smashing the [ __ ] thing and then
they get out in a way where it's like
well yeah they probably would have died
from that too so yeah you have to
suspend your disbelief but the movie is
just fun so that's like it's not hard to
cuz yeah anything in this film that's
ridiculous it causes you to suspend your
disbelief and there's a lot you'll find
cheesy but I keep saying it works for
this particular film a lot of it
wouldn't work for the type of film
Jurassic Park is but it works for the
type of film Jurassic world is my kids
escape [ __ ] when they [ __ ] find
the Jeep's oh cool homage to the first
one but then they were able to start off
the Jeep that was a little bit
yeah that's [ __ ] none of that really
bother me honestly but the moment that
the one cheesy moment that really did
make me go what was when Bryce Dallas
Howard and Chris Pratt kissed it's like
I guess she saved his life but if she
didn't she'd be a total [ __ ] [ __ ] a
lot of this is her fault why
everything's going to hell a flying
dinosaur I think it's a pterodactyl
a flying dinosaur is about to kill Chris
Pratt the only reason the flying
dinosaurs about to kill Chris Pratt says
Bryce Dallas Howard really [ __ ] up so
the only right thing to do was [ __ ]
save Chris Pratt and Chris Pratt gets up
and kisses her and I was like what I
didn't feel anything really leading up
to that and maybe a kiss at the end of
the movie might have made more sense but
there was so much adventurous I'm like
when did they have time to develop
romantic chemistry exactly and also real
quick another major complaint I'm
hearing is what they did with BD Wong
like they do turn him into a villain but
in my personal opinion I like how they
turned him into a different character
rather than just making it a fun Easter
egg cameo where we go oh hey it's that
one Asian dude who was like in a scene
or two in the first Jurassic Park they
turned him into a more of a character
that actually plays a real pivotal part
like Mark Ellis from schmoes know said
his character goes down some Bond
villain territory I don't disagree with
that but I just really appreciated the
fact that they gave a turn on a
character that could have just been an
Easter Egg all right so the last couple
things I feel like I need to talk about
I don't even talking for a while I love
that whole sequence when they unleash
the Raptors to go help them take down
the indominus rex I mean there was a
clever twist there I mean because at
that point the audience is thinking oh
yeah well we got teased from the trailer
where the raptors are gonna help fight
like it's one thing I thought the
trailer did right which was eluding us
down a different path but when the
Raptors immediately encounter the
indominus rex chris pratt quickly
realizes that they've been spliced with
Raptor DNA then we get even more of what
we want so we get this other take on the
Raptors
and then a part of me was kicking and
going you know it's cool and all but I
do miss when the Raptors were like scary
[ __ ] creatures and then they bring it
back where the Raptors become ferocious
killers again and they're like bum me
out in the right way because I was
invested in that part of the story so I
was like oh man that really sucks for
Chris Pratt I really like those Raptors
but there's a moment that I feel like
people should acknowledge a little bit
more like the Raptors have turned on
everyone they're all shooting at the
Raptors as the rapper's like [ __ ]
annihilating everyone and Chris Pratt
has this one moment where he can easily
take out one of the Raptors but he looks
at it in the eyes and he just
take the shot like he's contemplating
because he still understands the
emotional side of the animal
he doesn't just look at it as hope this
is now a bad creature and of course
someone else just closed the Raptor up
but that moment was smart to include
because it doesn't make the finale seem
so convenient now the finale here we go
it's what this [ __ ] film is all
[ __ ] about right [ __ ] here the
number one reason you must watch this on
IMAX like before the big battle the
Raptors come in you know they they have
those moments in the Jurassic Park films
with a Raptors corner and the group of
main characters and Chris Pratt is able
to get through to the Raptors and I like
that moment like they gave the Raptors
more personality I keep feeling I'm
saying rappers but they gave the Raptors
more personality you could see that
they're their animals they're thinking
and feeling animals like more than just
nature they're being nurtured and I love
that moment because even though you know
your main characters are not gonna get
killed off I liked how the Raptors were
like emotionally confused on what to do
they never became like a puppy and just
wanted to get pet all the time but you
see these decisions made when the
indominus rex um reappears and the
raptors start going after it that was an
intense scene and I was like [ __ ] man I
love those Raptors and then when the kid
was like we need more teeth and then
Bryce Dallas Howard had an idea then I
immediately remembered oh yeah that's
right they teased the t-rex and I
remember the director saying that it was
the same t-rex from the original so it's
like an aged version but they only
teased it for like like very briefly
they don't keep coming back to it so
they're not really setting it up
but of course Bryce Dallas Howard goes
running and she only she's the t-rex and
I wasn't there going
yup saw that coming I was like that is
exactly what I wanted to see happen the
original t-rex versus the brand-new
hybrid indominus rex epic [ __ ] battle
i mean it's cool because like at first i
was like okay it's gonna suck if the
t-rex just starts owning but the t-rex
is getting his ass handed that would
just make the most sense the t-rex is
[ __ ] old with the cheesiest [ __ ]
moment hi
here's so [ __ ] cheesy but I love it
was when the Raptors appears and starts
running in slow motion to help the t-rex
was like okay this kind of doesn't fit
but I love it is
so cheesy because in you know the t-rex
only way for the t-rex I have one it did
need help and it was cool because in the
first one the t-rex the same t-rex
actually kind of saves the main
characters by killing the Raptors and
this one it's like they work together it
was a cool flip for the fans of the
series because the first Jurassic Park
the t-rex was [ __ ] terrifying it was
even really scary in the second one but
as a fan of the series you find yourself
rooting for that [ __ ] t-rex and like
Jeremy John said it best like they go
deep blue sea where they get the
indominus rex near the water then water
creature who hate the shark just small
takes the indominus rex down into the
water and they foreshadow that because
there's a scene where the indominus rex
is chasing after the kids the kids jump
into the water and the indominus rex is
the first the only the only two and it's
the only time we need ominous rex is
like yo maybe i shouldn't continue
chasing them so with like four shadows
that the way to defeat this dinosaur is
push it into the water essentially it's
really liked how these dinosaurs were
not portrayed as like soulless creatures
they're portrayed as animals that think
and feel so that moment when the t-rex
you know like doesn't eat the [ __ ]
Raptor i thought was cool because they
were like you know what man you a cool
little rap turd you had my back and word
of the night at the end i can't say that
word tyrone Magnusson say that worked so
yeah i had a great [ __ ] time at the
end of the day this one has one mission
one task that's really setting out to do
and that is to entertain the [ __ ]
come out of you it does so in a
suspenseful entertaining way that I
haven't felt in a while was really
thrilling I had a blast go for the fun
go for the IMAX experience have a good
day anyway guys if you're new to the
channel you can subscribe to the real
rejects you can follow us on Facebook
Instagram Twitter and vine where if we
get enough followers we can get product
placement or should I say more product
placement Oh what products that I
actually get placement for recently have
I promoted anything recently huh was it
subtle no no no the
the one thing I got a product placement
for it was not so but the next one when
I tried sneak in really well I wanted to
just seep into your subconscious and be
like ooh I do want ships of like ah but
I did it away